bang-bang what's up lunch money time on
a Monday while Wall Street's trying to
get rich the rest of us just trying to
get our lunch money right the beautiful
intelligent plain Amer Nova guest host
may be full time host we're still
deciding looks like an angel or a ghost
a ghost you said it not me
don't forget lunch - now sponsored by
block-by-block fights got three products
you could deposit crypto they'll give
you a u.s. dollar loan you can buy and
sell crypto or my favorite product as a
user and an investor is an
interest-bearing account that pays up to
eight point six percent ap why go in the
description of this video you can click
on the link there go sign up tell them
lunch money sent you they'll give you a
bunch of cool [ __ ] and you won't regret
it
what's going on at the protest okay well
the protests are raging on and pretty
much every city in America what's your
take my take is the same as last week I
think the people have had enough and
this was bound to happen I agree I want
to address Friday I read all the
comments I don't think I was clear I
think that these protests would happen
regardless of the economic situation but
I think that the economic situation
magnifies all of the issues so let's
clear that up second of all I wrote a
really long piece today it's probably
the longest piece that I've written in
years about it's good I read it oh it's
only good because I read it
polina actually helped me edit it it's
about America in turmoil and the racial
economic and power privilege it talks
all about the militarization of the
police etc go read it you'll understand
how I think the one thing that I will
say though is I never thought that I
would see this quickly
protesters gained the upper hand we saw
last week where protesters literally
chased the Minneapolis police out of the
police station and then lit the police
station on fire this weekend we saw cop
cars burning in the middle of Manhattan
in Union Square on Saturday night they
had lit three
cop cars on fire throwing Molotov
cocktails in the heart of New York City
in the United States it's crazy but you
know what people are hurting they want
to be heard it's probably about time
that we start listening what's your
favorite positive video from the
protests okay so I liked one where the
cops got down on one knee and everybody
you know was like thank you and this is
what we wanted and and then they started
walking with the protesters my favorite
is the sheriff oh wait no I haven't in
Minnesota
okay I don't think this is protest
related but it happened during that time
it was this little kid that went around
is started hugging everyone the little
Todd's are a little two-year-old hugging
everyone in a park so cute okay all
right well the sheriff and Minister I
think it was st. Paul or we're somewhere
in mini apple or Minnesota basically
said look we put down our batons we put
down all of our riot gear and he's
talking to the protesters she goes I'm
here to listen what do you guys want to
do and they said walk with us and he
literally just hypes him up and goes
let's go where we walk a walk all night
and he just starts walking with the
protesters and I think it's a signal of
we just need more listening we need more
empathy and actually we would be in a
better position if more people said hey
we're here we don't agree with this
either right that's the most powerful
thing is if police officers say I don't
think that police officer should be
killing citizens it will drastically
accelerate the recovery from all this I
think I think it's just there the cops
want to show that they're you know
strong and whatever so they're just
ratcheting up the force in a time where
you should be doing the opposite don't
forget the police are here to protect
and serve us supposedly let's go to the
CFO survey maybe I should tell everyone
again to be kind to their friends yeah
that's probably true okay it's going
with a global CFO survey so global CFOs
are more negative on the economy and
expect big coronavirus hit to their
company in 2020 is this shocking to
anybody today in no-shit
news CFO oh sorry kids show can't can't
be cursing I've seen videos now
two-year-old saying bang bang shoutout
to the two-year-old but no I think that
this is it just reiterates the whole
idea raised the economic data is getting
worse and worse
it's still getting worse and we also are
seen the stock market rally there's
obviously a dislocation between stock
prices and the economic data CFO's
though although they may see their stock
prices going up they see the economic
realities that don't like be having
revenue and profits fall off a cliff
they're eating into their cash reserves
and so most of them are saying that they
expect 2020 to be a really tough year no
surprise there but also they're saying
that they believe that there will be
some sort of realignment between the
stock prices and the economic reality
yeah more so that the stock prices are
going to fall back down who knows what
will happen and why the stocks are going
up right now because the stock market is
not a representation of the actual
economy it's a representation of central
bank actions which means that if all of
a sudden the Federal Reserve steps in
and says hey the stock market's falling
you know what we're gonna do we're gonna
flood the market with dollars
sophisticated investors know that when
you flood the market with dollars that
means that you stop the falling of asset
prices and you actually drive a massive
recovery in asset prices and so what it
investor's do they all sort of buying
stocks which only perpetuates the
recovery of the stocks is there's more
buying than selling now in the Federal
Reserve's just pumping cash into the
market there's also a bunch of studies
and data that have come out that show
the stimulus checks that got given to
people right within those two weeks of
the stimulus checks went out a bunch of
retail investors like on Robin Hood in
other places started buying stocks or
stimulus money was going into it and
then lastly there's a bunch of
speculation that hey we're gonna get a
vaccine we're gonna get some sort of
drug for coronavirus we're gonna get out
of all of this and so you put all those
things together and you get a rallying
stock market which again leads to wealth
inequality at the same time that 40
million people are losing their jobs and
lower socioeconomic environments you
have the rich people the people who own
stocks making money it's just we're
getting to the place where we've been
for a long time so this is it playing
out CFO's believe that they'll be ready
I feel like in times of crisis just
everything gets exacerbated in mag
defied in it what is it called okay yeah
you get what I'm saying all right
speaking of what's going on with the
squid he's saying that because Goldman
was once called an evil vampire squid
with its tentacles all around there's
sucking boy okay so Goldman Sachs you
wanna hear something shocking sure hit
me it's shorting the dollar that's not
surprising really no because here's why
is remember when those stock prices are
falling all the asset prices are falling
that means the dollar strengthening
great it's a it's a
numerator/denominator thing that's all
denominated in dollars so in order for
the asset prices to fall it means the
dollar has to strengthen as the dollar
strengthening people eventually say hey
it's I gotta strengthen forever right as
the prices aren't gonna go down forever
and so at some point people start to
short the thing the question is always
when's the right time to do it right
Goldman thinks now other people think
that they've got a ways to go we'll see
who's right and who's not but the idea
that the dollar has to weaken against
other assets and against other
currencies in order to get a full-blown
recovery is not new but most economists
and investors know that that will happen
it's all about timing they highlighted
the Norwegian krone Marone
crony yeah krome saying what that
they're going long that it is
well-positioned to outperform during the
remainder of the coronavirus crisis why
the Norwegian why do they say that so
they they're they're recommending to
short the USD Krone pair which is pretty
crazy that they're even putting that
type of recommendation but I mean look
it is what it is at the end of the day
we're gonna see how this plays out this
is all a game of timing there's very few
people who would argue that we were just
a deflationary environment how long
would that last nobody knows and the
dollar has to weaken in order to get
some sort of recovery
Coleman thinks now is the time and
here's the beauty of shorting things is
if you're right you can make a lot of
money if you're wrong you can get your
face ripped off and so we're gonna see
what a what happens but how do not want
to get my face
okay sorry that's like a normal piece of
language but go ahead sometimes have
really crazy like metaphors and stuff
that I dunno that's just it's just a
normal terminology go ahead suck suck
trump call box and trump box so trump
and suck spoke on the phone on friday
what do you think they said to each
other I think that Mark Zuckerberg
explained his position on social media
and Donald Trump probably generally
appreciated it and liked it doesn't mean
that it's right but doesn't also mean so
let me get this straight so Trump right
now does not like Twitter because
Twitter is trying to censor him and then
he's appreciating suck because Facebook
is trying to just be a platform and let
him say whatever he wants look there's a
lot of reasons to not like Mark
Zuckerberg right there's a lot of people
don't like I personally like him right
met the guy worked at Facebook I'm
biased but there's very few people who
think he's dumb and I think that the
position he's taking is the right one on
this case because if we get into a world
where the platforms are making decisions
on what's true and what's not
I agree that is a really bad position
because let me give you two examples
last week Donald Trump tweeted something
and use the terminology when the looting
starts the shooting starts which is a
reference to a racist comment from years
ago
he claims he knows racist who cares but
Twitter put a interstitial over top of
it or a warning that basically said look
this encourages violence and then Trump
doubled down and posted on the White
House Twitter account so he basically
was challenging Twitter are you going to
not only censor me the president the
United States
by putting this up but are you also
going to do it to an official government
account now I believe that they did it
to both the problem is they did it to
the president into the White House
account but there was many many other
people who were tweeting the same thing
you can go to Twitter you can search
that exact phrase and they did not get
them to get though so I guess you this
is really tricky because you get into
the hole okay
if I am tweeting that exact tweet in
quotes but I'm using it to criticize the
tweet technically they would have to
censor me because it's the whole point
is if you're gonna apply it to one
person you have to apply to everyone
even if it's the president and then you
have to do to everybody else and that's
a problem that Twitter just it's gonna
be almost nearly impossible to enforce
and if they don't apply it to everybody
now you're just intentionally targeting
the president of United States which is
exactly what they want to see right like
like the government wants them to
basically do that so then they can say
hey you're just censoring us and they
can go after them now the other part of
this is again I keep saying to the media
you don't want this to happen
because now all of a sudden you're gonna
have Twitter who starts to play referee
on whether your articles are true so
this may make Twitter a publisher
instead of a platform well that that is
the argument that many people in the
government have right now is they're
saying that twitter has become a
publisher they're no longer a neutral
platform because they're making
decisions about the content that's not a
place well think about this imagine I
saw one of the Winklevoss twins tweeting
this and there are plenty of people who
think that this is a bad example but but
I generally think that directionally
this is a good way to think about it
imagine if the phone company started to
censor what you said on the phone
whether they would connect you or not
based on what you were saying I hope but
the whole point ends up being that like
they don't do that it's a truly neutral
thing I can call anyone through my phone
line and I can say whatever I want I may
get in trouble afterward by law
enforcement but the phone company
doesn't censor me that's a neutral
platform right okay mail same thing when
I write a letter the mailman will
deliver that mail through the US Postal
Service as long as I pay for the stamp
äj--
they they will deliver it regardless of
what I put in the message right yeah
Twitter now is stepping up and saying no
no we are actually going to determine
whether we delivered or not based on
what you're saying that takes a lot away
a lot of the neutrality Facebook has
chosen to go a different direction
here's what Zach said he said I've been
struggling with how to respond to the
president's tweets and posts all day
personally I have a visceral negative
reaction to this kind of divisive and
inflammatory rhetoric but I'm
responsible for real
acting not just in my personal capacity
but as the leader of an institution
committed to free expression so he's
really taking the stance of we're gonna
try to be neutral well and here's that
here's the crazy part right like one of
the signs of intelligence is to be able
to listen to other people's ideas and
not change your mind right and I forget
the exact coconut paraphrasing there and
basically what is happening here is we
have to remember that free speech is not
hey I guarantee you free speech as long
as you say things that I agree with
right free speech is challenged most and
is most important when somebody says
something you don't agree with so if you
go talk to a lot of military veterans
for example they'll say things like you
know what I fought for the right for you
to be able to bring the US flag that's
your that's your right that's your
freedom of speech right I've fought for
the right for you to talk [ __ ] to me now
I mean whoop your ass when you do it
right but you have the right to say it
you have the right to do those things
and so what ends up happening is free
speech is all about and it gets tested
the most when people are saying and
doing things that you don't agree with
that's what I think here we've gotten to
this nuanced world because then you get
into the world are you encouraging
violence are you actually hurting people
right super complex two platforms that
are - the most important the world
taking two different strategies we'll
see how it plays out but I think it's
worth paying attention to
absolutely and some of the best
conversations that you and I have are
when we disagree and we debate I end up
being right okay SpaceX let's keep going
what's going on with SpaceX SpaceX so we
live streamed the launch he yelled and
screamed and wooed I was just you know
giving out fun facts bang bang we made
it to space baby it was really cool I
don't know if that's really a mouse I
just was a mouse but then I read another
article where Elon Musk is literally
sending these like weirdly mutant mad
mice - okay so let's back up
3/6 had a launch on Saturday they
launched two humans to the International
Space Station it was the first time
since 2011 that astronauts have been
launched from the US soil and it's the
first time ever that a private company
has launched humans into space and it
was the first time that
reusable rocket has ever launched humans
to space this is a massive milestone and
inflection point I believe for space
exploration and it was just frankly
really inspiring to watch happen it was
really well done yeah evil on musk 20
years ago almost now eighteen years ago
set out to colonize Mars and for 18
years they've been working on this this
was one of the major milestones and so
it's just cool to see it happen it got
to the space station they are
successfully in the International Space
Station the next step will be in 30 to
120 days they will come back to earth
and so that's got to go well obviously
but we'll see how that plays out so long
SpaceX man I'm a big fan in a world of
really sad dark news I think this is
kind of a cool thing to celebrate
humanity's progress shooting some
rockets in space okay kylie jenner the
mouse conspiracy because i feel like you
you you don't want to talk about it cuz
you know i'm right and it was a mouse
maybe it was a mouse maybe it wasn't who
cares tech guys Google Mouse SpaceX
video all right let me know in the
comments if there's really a mouse on
the rocket or not
okay okay so do you understand that the
rocket was going so fast and was so hot
they would melt metal yes but these are
genetically engineered mice look up the
only thing that the Ninja Turtles of
mice getting shot into space and they
can survive yes they can survive any
sort of conditions okay
Elon Musk make God a reusable rocket
back to its thing do you not think he
can like engineer some mice to be able
to scurry on a rocket I don't think it's
that far-fetched okay and she says that
I have conspiracy theories sometimes
kylie jenner's speaking of conspiracies
so what's going on kylie jenner all
right so I don't know what Forbes is
doing so okay Forbes declared like
people literally lost their minds I
think it was two years ago three years
ago whenever it was two years ago 2018
they put her put Kylie Jenner on the
cover and said she is set to be the
first or the youngest ever self-made
billion
now there was a whole lot of controversy
around whether she's really self-made or
her family made her but then she sold
51%
she's a 51% of her company for six
hundred million dollars which puts a 1.2
billion dollar valuation on the company
so then Forbes said she is definitely a
billionaire we have seen we have gone to
the accountants office etc now Forbes is
saying well no no no hold on SEC so it's
proven she is definitely a billionaire
because she sought a company that she
owns anywhere between a hundred percent
to 90 percent there's debate on whether
her mom owns some of it or not now but
she sold it for 1.2 billion dollars
right and she got six hundred million in
cash and then the rest was in she still
in stock now all of a sudden Forbes
saying wait a second the public company
that bought it Coty they're having to
publish a bunch of financials and the
financials don't match what we were told
in the past and blah blah blah whatever
at the end of the day doesn't matter
Cody paid six hundred million dollars
for 51% as makers Valley in here of
course it values the company at one
point two billion dollars there's no
there's no getting around the fact that
the company's worth 1.2 billion dollars
because somebody paid it companies are
worth what somebody's willing to pay
doesn't matter what Forbes thinks or
anybody else Cody paid 1.2 billion
dollars for the company right and they
gave me $600 in cash and so there you go
it's over debate ended this is this is
this one I read this article it sounded
like a scorned girlfriend who just
wanted to get back in acts like Forbes
was just mad there was waiting you to
write so but they're saying that even
creating tax returns that were like
before again what they don't have any
proof of that that's the whole point is
it's this entire article is written
speculation classic classic okay
speculation okay but you know what I do
know as a fact Cody a publicly traded
company paid a 1.2 billion dollar
valuation for the company and this lady
owns at least a billion dollars worth of
that which makes you a billion so we're
walking and I just here he is oh my god
Kylie's a genius what does she tweet
about this article she said I could
think of a whole lot more things that we
should be focused on right now then how
much money I got she ain't wrong so
guess what let's
move on because there's a whole lot of
other things we should be talking about
like the lunch money winner oh all right
this week's winner is Brent Katie
because what did we ask people to do
last week we asked people to say how
they were gonna use the hundred dollars
to do good in the world and Brent had a
great idea he said if I win $100 I'll
multiply by ten and get to the lunch
money team's favorite food bank people
need to get to eat and get money get
paid so we like doing good that then
gets more good done so the multiplier
effect we're gonna send a hundred
dollars and that's gonna turn into more
money and Brett tell us where you donate
to no you're supposed to pick the food
bank oh my god okay so feeding America
is a good one
all right so we'll do feeding America
and that is it for lunch money today we
appreciate you guys watching don't
forget if you're concerned that you're
not getting notifications on YouTube you
can go down in the description or the
pinned comment and we've got the email
that goes out now every day so when we
publish you'll get an email so you don't
have to go to youtube and just get it
there but remember world's crazy right
now
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us trying to get our lunch money
right
polina is behaving being nice being
intelligent basically keeping me out of
trouble we'll see you guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on I'm an investor a
user and a huge fan what you're a bigger
fan of block fire than you are of me
block wise my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products they can give you a u.s.
dollar loan you can earn up to eight
point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6% it's pretty
compelling so click on the link in the
description say thanks to the folks that
block by subscribe to our channel like
the video annoy plan in the comment and
we'll see you guys tomorrow
and be kind to your friends